hay mucha división porque pues ahora
pasa como usted lo decía al senado y en
el senado los demócratas tienen una
mayoría sí pero es una mayoría simple y
precisamente este plan que acá le dicen
envió a perder tendrá que pasar en un
proyecto de reconciliación es decir en
un proyecto de mayoría simple de 51
votos los demócratas tienen justo esos
51 votos pero hay dos demócratas
precisamente dos miembros del propio
partido que se oponen a este proyecto se
han opuesto en los últimos meses a este
proyecto y son el joe manchin y
christina cinema y ellos argumentan que
pues no están de acuerdo en varios
puntos que tienen que ver con el cambio
climático tampoco están de acuerdo en
que sean las empresas los
multimillonarios como lo ha dicho
repetidas veces yo bailé en los que
paguen por este plan este plan
inicialmente era de 35 billones de
dólares pero precisamente por la
oposición interna del propio partido
demócrata de estos dos senadores que le
mencionaba pues se tuvo que rebajar este
plan entonces de inversión social en
plan social
75 billones de dólares y pues esto es
significó tener que reducir precisamente
en muchos planes sociales y en la
posibilidad entre otras cosas de que los
estudiantes tuvieran educación gratis
universitaria en este país que era una
de las cosas que cobijaba estos 3,5
millones de dólares iniciales usted
habla precisamente de la división por
parte de los senadores demócratas
krysten sinema y joe manchin
cuál es la posición de ellos en este
momento y si los demócratas lograrán
aprobar este plan antes del día de
acción de gracias como lo tenían
esperado
exacto había sido una fecha que ellos se
abrían y se habían impuesto y
precisamente la fecha la quieren firmar
antes del día de acción de gracias
porque el 3 de diciembre es una fecha en
la que no solamente se tiene que votar
nuevamente acá en eeuu el presupuesto
nacional sino también que se tendrá que
extender nuevamente el techo de la deuda
que hace unas semanas fue un gran debate
en washington entonces no quieren
precisamente que esto tenga que
aprobarse estos tres proyectos el
proyecto del plan social el techo de la
deuda y el presupuesto nacional está que
aprobarse en un mismo día para evitar un
cierre de gobierno para evitar un
posible default por no tener ese techo
de la deuda suspendido así que eso es lo
que quieren los demócratas evitar a toda
costa que se llegue a este mundo el 3 de
diciembre pero en los reportes que hemos
leído del congreso todavía manchin no se
ha pronunciado al respecto no ha dicho
que va a votar efectivamente a p a favor
del plan social a pesar de que
recordemos se había comprometido
anteriormente a que si la cámara hace
una semana aprobaba el plan de
infraestructura él aprobaba el plan
social pues todavía no se sabe la
respuesta de mancini y la de christina
si nava si bueno esperaremos si lo
logran aprobar antes del 13 de diciembre
como usted nos dice gracias cristóbal
por su reporte